Speaker 1: Donald Trump looks scared as hell in
a deranged new video attacking the recent report
from the January six Trump Riot Committee. We're
going to look at the clip. This guy seems nervous.
This guy seems scared, even though I don't believe
he will see even a single day inside of a prison
cell no matter what happens. He doesn't want to
be the indicted president. He doesn't want to
have the next four years of his life. Who knows
how many years he has left tied up dealing with
a criminal trial. Look at Trump. Check this out.
Speaker 3: We wanted security. We wanted safety.
There was no insurrection and
there wasn't going to be an
insurrection. It was made up by these sick people.
Speaker 1: I've never seen Trump look like this,
behave like this, talk like this.
Speaker 3: Nancy Pelosi and the
DC mayor refused. If they had listened to me my
recommendation, none of this would have happened.
Speaker 1: Now, remember, we've learned since
first Trump kept saying, I wanted 10 to 20000
troops to protect the Capitol, and Nancy
Pelosi turned him down. And what we realized
was Nancy Pelosi didn't turn anything
down. Trump didn't request 10 to 20000
troops to protect the Capitol. It's actually even
sicker. We've now learned Trump wanted 10,000
troops to protect him on January 6th, him not to
protect the Capitol, to protect him. It's insane
that that's actually the truth of the matter.
Speaker 3: And you wouldn't have heard about
January 6th as we know it. They covered up
multiple tweets and they cover it up a video
which were censored by Twitter and
the FBI, in which I called for law
and order and for no violence.
Speaker 1: This this should be
an exhibit at whatever trial is forthcoming.
Speaker 3: And then they pushed an absurd and
discredited story where I supposedly lunged for
the steering wheel in an attempt to commandeer
a presidential limousine. Think of it. I
lunged for a steering wheel and they believe
that story. Nobody believes that story.
Speaker 1: The committee jump cuts doing
a lot of work here. I can only imagine what the
experience of watching Trump film this was like.
Speaker 3: Early even discussed the
catastrophic security failures at the Capitol,
and they didn't discuss the other thing, the
reason that everybody went there, the election,
which was a corrupt disaster. They did not discuss
why the doors were flung wide open for people
to walk right in, and they didn't discuss the
role of federal informants. Most importantly,
the UN Select Committee did not produce a
single shred of evidence that I in any way
intended or wanted violence at our Capitol.
The evidence does not exist because the
claim is baseless and a monstrous lie. They
know it. It's just like the Russia, Russia,
Russia hoax. This is absolutely no different.
It's misinformation. The only thing they're good
at cheating in elections. Misinformation.
Speaker 1: Remember, there was no
cheating in the election by Democrats.
Speaker 3: The events of January six were
not an insurrection. They were a protest that
tragically got out of control and which the left
has been weaponizing ever since. To censor, spy
on and persecute American citizens. The entire
phony hoax is about taking away your speech. Take
it away your vote and take it away your freedom.
These are sick people. These are Marxists,
and they are very dangerous and very big.
Speaker 1: Now, as you know, there would really
be no connection between Marxism and any of the
things that Donald Trump is talking about that
is unhinged. And understand that with the jump
cuts where it's like Trump's in a different
part of the screen every time they cut it.
And we know why this happens, because we've
seen the uncensored video of Trump trying to
record these things. He can barely speak, and
it's really just a triggering experience for
him. I can only imagine that given that this
was the best video they could put together,
that this guy was just exploding behind the
scenes about this thing. He seems scared. He seems
terrified. He doesn't want to be the indicted
president, which he may be. I don't know what
the big 2023 story is going to be, but if I were
a betting man at this point, I might be saying
it's the Trump indictment. We will see. We
will take a break and be back right after this